So, before we finish out the tutorial series, I just wanted to give you an overview and
just really concrete what Blueprint is doing, how it's functioning, and then I also want
to give you a little tip at the end of the series on how to open multiple doors
with one button press, because I thought that'd be a nice little bonus addition.
Again, you don't need to go back to it, and if you feel like you're comfortable
enough with Blueprints at the moment, that's great.
I just wanted to give you some, really drive home the point of Blueprint.
So let's talk about flow.
As we saw when we were debugging, flow always reads from left to right, so just make sure
your Blueprints are always set up in such a way where the information is readable, we've
not got crossing wires, and that all your information is going from left to right.
Events are functions that are often triggered by external influences, so as we saw before
when we added beginOverlap and endOverlap, they were impacted by the player overlapping
them, which is what we mean by external influences.
Something has happened that has caused this event to fire.
We can do functions of macros, similar to C++, which was a little bit outside the scope
of this tutorial, but again we can still do functions of macros within Blueprints.
And we have input and output on the right side of nodes.
So you've got inputs on this side, which is the string, so we're printing in a string
that says out in this instance, bad choice of wording there, but I think you understand
what I mean.
And then you've also got the outputs on the right hand side there.
We've got a whole list of different Blueprint variables, again we used a boolean in our example,
we also used a door reference, but you can get bytes, integers, names, vectors, enums,
whole list of things here.
And as you continue your Blueprint journey, you'll get more familiar with these concepts,
and also we got a variable and we set a variable, so we call them getters and setters,
and they're just all part of the power of creating Blueprints with variables.
When we're talking about Blueprint components, we can hold a whole host of information.
When you click that component dropdown list, we were only really adding door frames and
doors and begin overlaps, but there's a whole host of components that you can use here.
You may have been confused by that default root scene component that you might have
seen come with the Blueprint.
That's given to all actors, you can actually get rid of it if you want, but the main
thing to keep in mind is that you can child and parent the components like we did with
the door and the door frame, and all components will exist in that list.
We have level Blueprints, which we didn't touch upon in this example today because
we put all the functionality within that Blueprint, but if we wanted to add any functionality
to the level Blueprint, we could go ahead and do that.
You can go to the level Blueprint by going into your first person map, and you can
select the Blueprint graph here, and open level Blueprint, and there's a level Blueprint
in here where if we type begin play, and again you don't need to do this, and if
I print the string here, and I say level loaded, we'll just give it one exclamation
mark now.
And if we compile and save, and when we play the level, you can see that it says
level loaded in the top left hand corner of the screen there.
And all that means is that we've got some information specific to the context of this
level that we can do here.
Now you only really want to be doing certain things on level Blueprint, because say you
go from one level to the next, if you put all your door code on this level Blueprint,
if you went to a new level, say level 2, you'd have to redo all that door functionality.
So the good thing about us housing it inside of a door Blueprint like this one, is that you can
use this door across multiple levels, and all the information is housed within that
Blueprint.
So that's really useful to know.
You can have data only Blueprints, which only contain code and script, and more often
than not this will be the programmers on your team that are using them, but you
can use them to tweak properties or set items with variations, and they're impacted
in more of a compact editor.
So again, just good information, useful information for you to know about there.
We didn't touch upon Blueprint interfaces, as I said at the start of the tutorial here,
Blueprint interfaces can be used as a communication method from one Blueprint to another, so
as you continue your scripting journey, definitely look out for Blueprint interfaces, because
it can be a really powerful way of just sending a message from one Blueprint to another.
Blueprint communications, we didn't touch upon casting, but you can cast, you can get
an object reference and cast to say, is this the thing that you're looking for?
Again, Blueprint interfaces are something that where you can send a message from one Blueprint
to another, and you can also use event dispatches, which binds one or multiple events,
and those can actually be called on the level Blueprint, a little bit outside of the
scope of today's tutorial, but just to make you aware of these interface and functions.
And the way we think about Blueprint scripting is that it's a compiler software that turns
source code into machine language that can be executed by the CPU, so that requires changing
depending on the hardware and operating system, and when the script has been created,
it needs to be compiled.
So as you saw in our example, we had to keep compiling and saving, and that just makes
sure Unreal knows what new code has been added so that it can execute it correctly.
And then to finish off, we just want to talk about the Blueprint scripting framework here,
and it's essentially Blueprints are all compiled into bytecode, so it's processed
by a virtual machine, the virtual machine translates it by bytecode into the instructions,
and the hardware can understand what is actually being processed, and then we nativize
the Blueprint so we can take the Blueprint visual language and convert it to C++, which
essentially just means, you know, you can have larger projects, it processes the code
more quickly, and that's the kind of overview of Blueprint scripting framework.